it seems like only yesterday that the
office the American take on the PVCs
original workplace comedy closed its
doors and while many members of its
memorable cast have moved on to other
projects or pursuits we can't help but
wonder what ever happened to David
Denman the actor who played Pam's
ex-fiance Roy Anderson we know Roy
struck it rich with his own gravel
company married a restaurant owner and
even learned how to play piano
she's got away
don't know what it is but all that took
place in the fantasy land of Scranton
Pennsylvania so what did Denman really
do after the office let's take a closer
look at what he's been up to since
viewers said goodbye to Dunder Mifflin
he bossed around Steve Jobs well he
bossed around the Ashton Kutcher version
of Steve Jobs listen Steve you're good
you're damn good Denman played the small
but important role of programming
pioneer and pong creator al Alcorn in
the 2013 biographical drama jobs though
it's not the most memorable part in the
critically panned film
not everyone can claim that they hurled
a profane insult at the late co-founder
and former CEO of Apple that's a long
way from stacking boxes for Dunder
Mifflin but that wasn't Denman's only
2013 gig he also stepped into the shoes
of private McQuarrie in the
post-apocalyptic sci-fi action flick
after earth the second movie to star
father and son duo will and Jaden Smith
might want to go easy on Sarge that's
the prime commander's son right there
the film was widely panned by critics
and viewers alike and it has gone down
as one of both Smith's and director M
night Shyamalan least memorable projects
fortunately for those involved it didn't
turn out to be quite the career
demolishing disaster it may have seemed
Shyamalan rebounded with split in 2017
well both Smith's always have plenty of
projects in the pipeline as for Denman
after Earth's failure definitely didn't
stop him from landing more roles he went
to boot camp I do have a gun in my cubby
and I will use it in order to prepare
for his role as Boone in the
biographical war thriller 13 hours the
secret soldiers of Benghazi didn't put
himself through boot camp but not just
to learn how to shoot guns
the actor who started the flick
alongside fellow office alum John
Krasinski wanted to really get in the
mind of elite operatives
he told backstage they're of a different
ilk they do stuff that I don't
necessarily understand and put
themselves in harm's way without batting
an eye Denman was also surprised to
learn about the positive impact the
has had on the actual secret soldiers of
Benghazi saying wouldn't these guys came
up after a screening and said we watched
the office like crazy it got us through
so much i sat there in awe that some guy
overseas trying to protect our interests
was using a silly comedy as a survival
tool my brain had an explosion I was
really moved by that all we want to know
is how many times did those badass
soldier's force the offices Jim and Roy
to reenact their on-screen rivalry kill
Jim Halpert
he put a ring on it though dead man
hasn't spent much time in the spotlight
for his various supporting roles his
marriage to Swedish American actress and
former fear the walking dead star
Mercedes Mason has garnered the
attention of celebrity adoring media the
couple tied the knot in 2014 and Denman
celebrated their one-year anniversary on
Instagram it really does look like every
day is getting better for the two or
should we say three Denman and Mason
took to Instagram to announce that they
were expecting their first child and in
January 2018 Mason gave birth to a baby
boy as usual Denman headed over to
Instagram to share the news and
compliment his wife for being such a
champ no stranger to the small screen
though Denman hasn't really been a
leading man yet you've definitely seen
him on some of your favorite shows he's
made supporting appearances on person of
interest
Vegas how to get away with murder two
and a Half Men impressed me Mad Men and
true detective come to think of it he's
actually been pretty hard to miss he's
also been featured as a prominent
recurring cast member in Parenthood and
outcasts with an ever-growing resume
expect to keep seeing Denman pop up on
your favorite series for years to come
that is if he isn't busy landing larger
roles on the big screen he rubs elbows
with the Hollywood elite in 2017 didn't
Ben appeared alongside some big-name
talent and director Steven Soderbergh
heist comedy Logan lucky as car dealer
moody Chapman I love stick I'm a big fan
of stick the film boasts a cavalcade of
household names including the likes of
Channing Tatum Adam driver Katie Holmes
and Daniel Craig certainly not bad
company for denman especially
considering how successful the kooky
caper turned out Logan lucky gained
critical praise for its goofball humor
and pitch
perfect ensemble cast and it stands out
as a recent highlight on Denman Seavey a
bright future in film we certainly
haven't seen the last of Denman who's
come a long way since playing Roy in
2018 the versatile actors start
alongside Kelly Macdonald in the Mark
turteltaub directed movie puzzle the
film centers around a suburban mother
who discovers her penchant for puzzles
changing both her and her family's lives
it's also an adaptation of the 2010
Argentine film rumba Cabezas which was
nominated for the Golden Bear at the
Berlin International Film Festival for
denman though it's another step in the
right direction toward an increasingly
impressive filmography thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]